- [Voiceover] The quadratic expression
x-squared plus five x plus c
is a perfect square.
It can be factored as x plus d-squared.
Both c and d are positive
rational numbers.
What I wanna figure out in this video
is what is c, given the information
that we have right over here?
What is c going to be equal to?
And what is d going to be equal to?
Like always, pause the video
and see if you can figure it out.
Let's work through this together.
We're saying that x-squared
plus five x plus c
can be rewritten as x plus d-squared.
Let me write that down.
So this part, this part,
x-squared plus five x plus c,
we're saying that,
that could be written as x plus d-squared.
This is equal to x plus d-squared.
Now we can rewrite,
x plus d-squared is going to be equal to
x-squared plus
two dx
plus d-squared.
If this step, right over
here, you find strange,
I encourage you to watch the videos
on squaring binomials or on
perfect square polynomials,
either one, so you can see the pattern
that this is going to be.
X squared plus two times the product
of both of these terms plus d-squared.
When you look at it like this,
you can start to pattern
match a little bit.
You can say, alright,
five x, right over here,
that is going to have
to be equal to two d,
and then, you can also say,
that c is going to have
to be equal to d-squared.
Once again, you can say
two d is equal to five,
or that d is equal to five halves.
We've figured out what d is equal to.
Now we can figure out what c is,
because we know that c needs
to be equal to d-squared,
gimme that orange color, actually,
so we know that c is equal to d-squared,
which is the same thing
as five halves, squared.
We just figured out what d is equal to.
Gonna be five halves, squared,
which is going to be 25 over four.
C is equal to
25 over four,
d is equal to five halves.
We're done.